ding dong Michael's gone but is he
really spoilers ahead while Laurie gives
a brief overview of what's happened to
her Alison and the rest of Haddonfield
after the events of Halloween kills
there are still some things left hanging
sure Lori talks about her and Alison now
living together and having a bit of a
dysfunctional relationship as well as
Haddonfield becoming consumed by the
grief and anger from Michael's killing
spree and sudden disappearance but the
new film sort of just glosses over some
pretty big lingering emotions and story
threads from the previous movie for
instance what were the consequences of
the Town causing one of the escaped
mental patients to fall out of the
hospital to his death also throughout
both previous films both Laurie and
Alison were ready to have Michael's head
on a silver platter and now they just
suddenly decide to stop after he
disappears even the absolute Massacre
that Michael enacts at the end of
Halloween kills barely gets any mention
of follow-up leaving the devastation of
it with no fulfilling resolution
truthfully Halloween ends doesn't
transition well from Halloween kills and
it makes a lot of what was built over
during the film's wild finale have no
lasting impact Michael Myers is no
stranger to Disappearing Acts since he
can literally vanish in a Flash if you
don't keep your eyes on him however it's
a little odd that Michael is just
suddenly gone from Haddonfield Without a
Trace after Halloween kills especially
since he was winning he was ripping
people to shreds on the streets of
Haddonfield and even got to kill Karen
just to Twist the knife in Lorry so why
would he leave it frankly doesn't make
much sense since he knew Lori was still
out there and he clearly wants to put a
knife in her he looks like an unbeatable
killing machine at the end of Halloween
kills so if there was any time for him
to have a final bout with Laurie it
would have been then plus it's not like
he went somewhere else to catch his
breath for a moment he's literally been
gone for years at this point and still
didn't look like he was going after Lori
anytime soon sure he looked like he was
in a weakened State when Cory finds him
but come on this is Michael Miles were
talking about he's not the type to leave
things unfinished while the original
continuity saw Michael motivated to kill
Laurie because of their familial
connection this Trilogy doesn't have
that all this Trilogy offers is
speculation in kills about how Michael
keeps returning to his childhood home
yet there's no motivation ever
established for why he goes after his
victims specifically so it needs to be
asked why does Michael care so much
about Laurie is it just because she's
the one that got away does he see her as
the ultimate kill because of how strong
she's been against him honestly what's
Michael's deal there's actually a lot
about Michael that's left unanswered how
is he able to withstand all the
stabbings beatings and damaging blows
he's taken throughout the years he
literally gets stabbed in the Heart by
Laurie in the film's final battle and
then suddenly Rises to nearly choker to
death what is it about Michael that's
made him more than a normal man for so
many years the film never provides that
answer and leaves Michael as ambiguous
as ever it's a choice that makes sense
given that Michael is always meant to
Simply Be This malevolent evil entity
with unclear motives but with this being
Lori and Michael's final boss it feels
like a missed opportunity to truly
understand the shape once Corey decide
is to give in to his more violent side
there's almost nothing that seems
capable of stopping him he enacts some
kills that are nearly as brutal as if
not more than Michaels and even brings a
big guy along for a tag team murder
match yet it's not hard to see why Corey
is near Unstoppable since the police are
often nowhere to be found throughout the
Halloween franchise the Haddonfield
police are never too incompetent and
would at least notice that people are
either disappearing or being brutally
killed here though there's barely a
mention that these people have
disappeared and Corey already runs into
any obstacles since the police don't do
too much no one even questions if
Michael is back given the string of
disappearances or that it's all
happening around Halloween maybe they're
off dealing with a different violent
occurrence in his darker depiction of
haddenfield but how did no one really
become aware that Corey's Rampage was
going on when Croy first comes across
Michael Myers while he's hiding in the
sewers he's not exactly in the best of
conditions he's clearly weakened from
the big fight at the end of Halloween
kills but he quickly regains his
strength after getting his first kill
with the help of Corey so if Michael is
ready to get back out there and start
killing again why is he basically tied
to the hip with Corey and only seems to
come out after he shows up seriously
Michael only leaves the sewer if Cory
ends up coming and picking him up on his
motorcycle which could have been a
hilarious visual to see does he have
stage fright now or something even on
Halloween day he just sits in his sewer
Hideout until Corey comes by to steal
his mask and it's just odd to see
Michael not go back to his killing
routine once he's got his strength back
it's legitimately one of the strangest
things about Michael in Halloween ends
and sadly keeps him off screen for
longer than any fan would expect or want
once Croy and Michael meets they start
to work together and a mass a decent
body count Corey seems to help maikora
gain his strength while Michael gives
Corey the power to tap into his evil
side however you can't help but wonder
by the end he was actually in charge in
this Dynamic for the most part it would
seem like Corey has control since he
seems slightly stronger than Michael for
most of the movie and is clearly leading
the kills however perhaps Michael was
conning us all along Corey's plan was to
see him go on a destruction spree
through Haddonfield before going off
into the sunset with Alison so it
doesn't really seem like he's dying on
the floor of Lori's house was a part of
the plan so maybe this was Michael's
plan all along he did follow Corey to
Lori's house after Corey took his mask
and it does lead to the big finale fight
between him and Laurie Michael Myers has
never seemed like much of a planner in
this franchise but maybe he's gotten
wise in his old age Lori and Frank's
awkward but adorable relationship in
Halloween kills was one of that film's
biggest highlights and ends up being a
very sweet part of Halloween ends
there's nothing more heartwarming than
seeing their natural chemistry flourish
and you desperately want these two to be
together after dealing with Michael
Myers for so many years Laurie deserves
some love in her life so do they end up
together well they don't share an
on-screen kiss or anything and we don't
see them boarding a plane to Japan as
they talk about during the movie however
it's a pretty safe bet that they do get
together after the events of the film
since their final moment together on
Lori's porch is fairly emotional there's
no definitive answer to whether or not
Laurie and Frank end up together but the
film does make you believe that it is
possible
with the traumatic history that Alison
has endured and had infield with both
her parents and Friends being slain by
Michael Myers it's not too shocking to
hear that she's looking to leave while
Laurie is able to keep her there through
guilt and concern Alison does find her
opportunity to leave when she meets
Corey and He suggests doing so while her
original plans to leave with Corey fall
through Alison does end up leaving
Haddonfield before the credits roll the
only question is where is Alison going
truthfully we'll probably never know the
answer as the scene of her leaving Adam
field is likely just to symbolize as
she's leaving the town for good maybe
though there can be a more intriguing
answer it's unclear whether or not
Halloween ends will really be the end of
the franchise and maybe the scene will
lead to a follow-up film or Trilogy
keeping up with Alison as she discovers
new Halloween Horrors and she tries to
start a new life in the final shot of
Halloween ends the camera moves
throughout Lori's house as an Omar to
the final scene of the original
Halloween film however there is one item
that sticks out in the final room
Michael's mask while this shot is likely
meant to symbolize her truly leaving
Michael behind he can't help but wonder
why didn't Laurie destroy the mask when
she pushed Michael's body into the
grinder it's kind of odd that she didn't
destroy it since Michael's mask is a key
identifier of him and a major symbol of
the fear he spread across haddenfield
maybe she needed it as inspiration to
finish the book she's been writing
throughout the film or just simply
wanted it because she wasn't completely
over him even after killing him perhaps
two this could be a hint that someone
else could pick up Michael's mask and
start a new reign of terror in
Haddonfield it's not too surprising to
see Halloween ends definitively kill
Michael Myers it's just strange that his
mask couldn't go with him Michael Myers
is dead by the end of Halloween ends and
Laurie seemingly has moved on so it
would be pretty easy to see this as the
last movie but the film is a little
shaky with its conclusiveness creating
some avenues for the franchise to return
yeah it seems conclusive Michael is dead
and Laurie has left Haddonfield however
Michael's mask just sitting on the table
leaves the impression that someone else
could pick it up to continue his legacy
it's extremely unlikely that this
franchise will continue under day golden
green and plumhouse Productions green
said that this entry is a conclusion of
his story plumhouse CEO Jason Blum added
that the company has no more rights to
make more Halloween films either but
could the franchise continue under
different hands even after Michael's
death the only thing that's harder to
kill than Michael Myers is a lucrative
franchise we've already seen that the
franchise is willing to bring in other
Killers besides Michael with Corey
mainly acting as this film's killer
while Michael hides in the sewers and
though Laurie is likely gone from the
franchise for good long time fans know
that she hasn't always led the films for
example Jamie Lloyd led a couple of
films and Halloween resurrections or a
whole new cast take on Michael after
Lori is killed why the hell you dressed
like me anywhere I'm telling you to be
Michael Myers I'm playing Michael Myers
Halloween ends might be the end of this
Trilogy and the franchise as we know it
but even while it emphasizes the end and
the title during the credits it doesn't
feel totally conclusive
[Music]